I think by now both of most of the
people that watch my channel know you
and then probably similar we're in the
same space so we could just we could
just discuss and think it would be fine
you know what you say that that we're in
the same space but that makes me think
that we're in the same safe space I
wanted to be in the same danger zone I
think we're in the same space but I
don't think we're on the same sides of
it and so we're kind of like on these
stuff I think we have we're in the same
discussion but we're not maybe not in
the same thing I've been impressed I've
been to be honest I've been impressed to
see like the variety of interviews
you're able to get like it's it's pretty
intense
I guess it's I think it's it's such a
it's a testimony to your true desire to
discuss that you're able to do because
you know you you did them you did the
because you did evergreen and then so
everybody kind of could have pegged you
in a certain way because you you were
criticizing with the way that evergreen
was making decisions but now you're
having all these discussions about
transition with transsexuals and
everything I was like wow how did how is
he able to how hardly trust him you know
and so I think that's a that's a just
definitely a testimony to to your your
style or the way that you engage in
conversation well I think that it's
similar with you I think there's
something that causes both both of us to
be able to to be so dinners on an
intellectual level because you're able
to do the two walk into any story any
narrative and and make a home out of it
like you can go into these different
movies and you make a home out of it you
can make sense of what's going on or you
can make it makes sense to other people
in a way and that that's a testament
trying to either to your plasticity or
or the the like the tool that the tools
that you have is like one of those multi
tools but can just fit in well I think I
think one of the things that I'm always
trying to do if I show I'm showing some
symbolic structure I'm always trying to
show all the sides and so it's like you
know
I talk about let's say I talk about
marginality I can talk about the dangers
of the margin but also the opportunities
of the margins and I always tried to to
shift between the two so that people
don't think that I'm I'm just advocating
a simplistic moral position you know
where I'm trying to kind of need a
picture of reality so so hopefully yeah
and I think I think in a way I've seen
I've been surprised sometimes of the
people that have said that they like
what I'm doing you know and people on
both sides that like what I'm doing and
then people on both sides that don't
depending on how they want to proceed me
like depending if they want to it's
interesting it's what for sure the
extreme seem to dislike what I'm doing
like that I get a lot of criticism from
the hard like the hard right are
criticizing me you know they call so
like what's there what's the essence of
their critique well they don't like that
I'm dead I not openly criticizing the
criticizing Jordan Peterson they don't
like that because they really just like
during Peterson and so they wish that I
was more those harder let's say in terms
of certain ideas because it's like I I
want to show let's say I want to show
the the advantage of having an authority
let's say but there's also serious
disadvantage of authority to like that
there's a danger in authority and
there's advantage in authority and so
I'm not gonna just show one side because
I think that's lacking but if you're if
you're in a political fight then you you
want it you want a weapon right and so
it's like I don't I don't feel like I
give people weapons and so I think
that's why it's why they not that's a
place where I think both of us are on
the kind of on the same page where
that's not what we want to do we want to
help create space for a discussion and
and a space where people can at least
try to understand each other rather than
just give people get people weapons to
beat each other on the head with yeah
yeah that's interesting about what
you're bringing up about Authority and I
was just watching your video on the
symbolism of 666
and in that video as in with many of
your videos in your talks
you mentioned the church fathers and the
that kind of evokes like literal
patriarchy which is kind of a
interesting term right now it's been
kind of commandeered by as a negative
symbol from the standpoint of a feminist
theory but when you say the Church
Fathers I can feel that there's this
warmth in in that relationship that you
have with those fathers would you like
to talk a little bit about like the
symbolic form of the patriarchy all
right someone asked me a question about
this in Chicago a few weeks ago and they
asked me they said why do you advocate
can you explain to us why you advocate
patriarchy and I was like really as I
don't think that I advocate patriarchy
the the problem is that let's say I see
I see let's say masculinity or the
masculine aspect as the if we could use
the word patriarchy let's say we use the
word patriarchy and so I think that
there's a there's a a type of discourse
a type of reality a hierarchy in society
there's a there's a hierarchy in society
and that hierarchy you could call it
patriarchy if you want because it does
tend to have a certain masculine
characteristic because it's it's it's
public it's has it has a certain amount
of use of authority all of that but the
thing is is that that hierarchy cannot
exist without the space in which to
exist
and so the mother or the feminine is
extremely important it's it's primordial
the only problem is that it becomes
difficult if you try to talk about it
because it is the secret it's the secret
it's the mystery it's the it's this it's
in the space in which discourse happens
it's the the question it's all of these
aspects of reality the private sphere
the home there's all these images of the
feminine of the womb let's say that are
that are important but the problem is
that if you try to make them into if you
try to make them into patriarchy then
your your you're actually acting against
the power of this feminine symbolism
like if you want the feminine symbolism
to act like an authority in the world
with a sword and like beating they're
like that's that's not that's just it
now you're becoming a man and you're
acting in a masculine manner
and so so I don't necessarily advocate
patriarchy I advocate to me the way to
see it is a is that one needs the other
you need for any hierarchy to exist
you need a space in which it exists you
know but that space also is given form
that they are given an answer or given
some structure through what you would
call patriarchy or any or a hierarchy
does that make sense you think so yeah
do you think that in the in the Bible
like there's an Old Testament God and a
New Testament God and they're both
referred to as father or kind of in the
masculine I believe there's some like
they pronoun at the very beginning but
it's usually assigned to a key do you
think that in the Bible just off the top
of your head I don't know if you've done
any thinking about this but is there a
an evolution of the masculine going from
an authority figure into the Sun like
the transit from the father into the
empowered son or the sacrificial son and
is there a softening or of the masculine
in that process well I don't how can I
say this I don't think so I mean I think
it's important or at least for
Christians it's important to think that
the God of the Old Testament is the same
as the God I mean you just mean it's not
like an another God and but what it is
true that the Incarnation creates a
difference in the sense that the
Incarnation opens up a space of
communion or shows communion to be the
manner in which we are we can become the
body of God or the body of Christ so
that the body of the Messiah and so hmm
there so there is a a manner in which we
can which shows more clearly the way in
which we can participate let's say in
the
of God and we see that happen in the New
Testament but there are already hints of
that in the Old Testament as well you
know there are these they're the the
classic image is the image of Elijah who
goes into the cave and is you know he's
distraught and he's trying to understand
the will of God and and and there's this
storm and there's tempest and he says
God is not in the storm the tempest then
finally says there's the still soft
voice and then he hears God in the still
soft voice so there are images of let's
say this difference that Christianity is
going to bring is there already is
already there in some places in the Old
Testament there definitely is let's say
the aspect of rigor which you find in
the Old Testament the kind of more let's
say the harsher aspect of reality is
their trials but we have to be careful
because we can't we we can't deny that
that's part of reality you just can't
avoid it if you try to if you try to
think that there isn't a certain
harshness to reality or there isn't a
manner in which if you don't if you're
not in line that you're going to face
the consequences of not being in line
then you're you're you're missing an
aspect of reality it's like if if you if
you I don't know if you if you cheat on
your wife and you beat your kids and you
and you start drinking and you do this
and you think that there's no
consequences to those actions it's like
no reality has there's a certain amount
of of objectivity to the way reality
lays itself out and if you if you don't
adir to that then you're gonna you're
gonna eat it you're gonna see you're
gonna suffer it's just gonna be
inevitable and and and the church
fathers really do represent the idea of
God's judgment as the consequence of
your actions themselves so it's not it's
they don't imagine God as this although
it can be portrayed that way but they
don't imagine God as an exterior being
that is saying oh you did this now I'm
gonna smack you around it's like well
you know if you don't fix the dykes in
your city and then there's a flood well
that's the God's judgment but it's also
the dykes that broke because you didn't
fix them yeah like they're the natural
consequences of your actions is the
judgment of
yeah there's a Indonesian proverb I
believe that says don't fear God fear
your own actions
yeah yeah that's and in the end but it
does end up showing you the nature of
reality so you could say something like
it does end up showing you the will of
God because it's the way that reality
lays itself out it's not it's not
arbitrary there are there actual it's a
reality that shows itself you know but
then the you know so what Christianity
tends to do is - first off she plays the
human person and the love of the human
part of a people between themselves and
their love towards God is the solution
to the problem right in the sense that
like and take the example of a dyke
again like if you love your neighbor and
you and you love let's say if you're a
leader and you love the people who are
under you then you're gonna fix the dike
but you're not gonna leave it because
you care until you're going and so that
that love becomes the the tool by which
reality can be transformed and can
become more can become more cohesive you
could say mm-hmm so what do you think
about the that accusation that you're
promoting the patriarchy of them like
what what is it about the the masculine
at least in history at least in New York
tradition that's that's apparent and
that can be construed as like
suppressing the woman or keeping the
feminine or the female under wraps or
under control or something like that I
mean I think that how can I say this I
think that on the one hand so you can
see it this way you could see it as
there's there's there's a positive and
negative aspect of masculinity there's a
positive and negative aspect of
femininity and those to a certain extent
are inevitable right they're just
they're just the in the very structure
of reality if you have a hierarchy the
hierarchy can be a point of like a head
it can be the point of coming together
of a group or whatever but it can also
be an abusive thing where it eats you
know it eats its
members and doesn't give back so so it
could have booked the feminine can also
be the same in the sense that the
feminine can be the space is the space
in which things happen it is that the
frame the question that in the beginning
like the the opening of discourse of so
it has an amazing quality of nurturing
of being you know the safe safety all of
that is is related to to the feminine
but then it can also be subversive it
can also be you know how can I say this
it can also be a destabilizing agent as
well because it's the space so it didn't
you asked to like like a question is
great because it actually framed reality
but if you drowned the world in
questions then all of a sudden you have
no certainty anymore and then things
start to fall apart I don't that make
I'm trying I'm speaking in very
metaphorical language here but I but I'm
it's hard to sorry for that no is there
it's sorry to it's hard to talk about
these things to and try to talk at all
levels at the same time huh do you think
that that's a fault in certain modes of
discourse that they try to constrain
thought or sense making to one level
yeah yeah definitely and I think that
that's the I think that that's been in a
certain manner the the problem of the
leveling of thought I would say has been
one of the problems of the modern age in
the sense that we we try we see
everything at the same level we don't
were not able to understand that you
know that like a good example I'll give
you an example of something that
happened to me recently I was in a I was
giving it a talk in Montreal and the
subject fell on purity right and the
idea of purity and then all of a sudden
I realize like the people in the
audience were I had taken the stance
that purity is evil like purity is that
right you because purity is a an
exclusion you exclude people you you
discriminate all that stuff like so so
exactly so so acts of pure
the Nazis wanted purity and all of this
right is this evil thing like a pure
race of pure people a pure identity all
of this is that and so and so they were
like you know how why do people engage
in this and this lady asked me this
question said why do people engage in in
in impurity like why do they engage in
that type of behavior and I was like I
couldn't believe this question I thought
the reason why she asked me this
question is because she's not able to
think at all levels at the same time
right she's not even able to think at
two levels at the same time and so I I
said you know so I said okay let's take
a case study it's like let's say you
have guests at your house and and
they're staying over for dinner and then
they're hanging out and they're hanging
out and you're looking at the time and
then it's like you know it's 11:00 and
it's 11:30 and it's 12:00 and it's one
o'clock in the morning and that the
guests are still there
it's like at some point you are going to
ask the guests to leave and when you ask
the guests leave you are engaging in an
act of purity you are saying this is
this is my home this is my house this is
my this is my thing my family whatever
like a chicken dish you could be your
family and then you have people who come
you have guests who come and at some
point it's great you have this engaged
but at some point they have to go
because you need to find your identity
again you need to find so your act
you're actually engaging in an act of
purity by at some point having your
guests go out the door and closing the
door locking your door and then you go
to bed it's like that that is an act of
purity and it's totally fine to do that
but you could you could have the same
the imagine the same situation where
someone comes to your door knocks out
the door and wants to just ask you
something
and you open the window and you scream
you say get out of here I'm gonna call
the cops right and so that's also an act
of purity it's just one is normal and
one is excessive right so it just
depends but you have to be able to think
at all levels and so when you talk about
immigration it's like people aren't able
to think and also to understand it you
will have to find some level of purity
in terms of immigration the question is
what is too much
is normal what is a normal level of
hospitality what is a normal level of
engaging with that which is foreign or
that which is new or stranger or the
stranger whatever like you need to just
find that balance but if you're not able
to think about it and you just think
purity bad then you're gonna then it's
gonna come back it's gonna come back and
you're gonna engage in it in ways that
you don't realize in the way like for
example when you see social justice
activists engage in extreme acts of
purity without even realizing that
they're reproducing the very thing that
they hate the very thing that they're
trying to fight in terms of of you know
like white privilege or all this stuff
that they that they yeah yeah I was just
thinking about that because I'm working
in the Evergreen documentary and there's
this extended hour of students some
going off about how much they hate the
police and at the end of this session
they start to they they all start to
focus on one man who's typing on their
phone and start accusing him of taking
pictures and uploading them to like
Brett Bart or something like that and
then and then you see that they really
love to police they don't want to be
policed yeah they want it like community
policing is them having the power which
doesn't really shake out because it's
just the will of the mob and whoever can
claim the most victimhood and stuff like
that it's crazy yeah and I think that
that's why that's why if you if you're
able to to think about these things
clearly then you don't you don't get
stuck with them by accident and that's
that's always the thing it's like if if
you're not if you don't deal with
reality like if for example if you if
you don't if you think that we talked
about the idea that God like let's say
there's an aspect of God which is like
which is harsh let's say that that has a
harshness to it
if you don't want to engage with that
and think about it in a reasonable
manner then you're it's gonna come back
to bite you and you're gonna find
yourself acting like that and you're not
going to realize that you're doing it as
you're saying how it's horrible that the
God of the Old Testament has harshness
to him and then with your you'll end up
doing because it's part of reality it
it's an aspect of reality that you have
to
with in a balanced manner do you think
that um no it does what do you I would
like to explore like how do we diagnose
that leveling of thought without
necessarily getting conspiratorial and
saying that like the mainstream media is
doing I think we're doing it to
ourselves I think but maybe maybe like
maybe it's working to the advantage of
some people but what do you think it is
about in modern times you said or you
framed it as a modern problem what what
is it about modernity that has led us
into you know this leveling of thought
or this this almost not even binary
because they can't see the flip side of
it well I think I think it's horrible to
say this but I think it's the it's not
horrible but a lot of people will be
really annoyed that I say this but I
think it it is in a certain manner the
fact that scientific thinking has let's
say scientific thinking has taken over
the horizon of thought and that people
want to approach everything as if it is
equivalent to a scientific problem
because scientific problems are usually
quantitative and they're usually
phenomena that is measured in terms of
quantity but when if you want to think
of different levels you can't level
everything like that you can't you know
you have to be able to see hierarchies
of purpose hierarchies of hierarchies of
reasons why things exist hierarchies of
beings even and you have to be able to
see it that way you know and that's why
like there's so much going on right now
which is which is good in the sense that
the fact that everybody is trying to
talk about emergence complex systems all
of this stuff is showing that the the
simplistic you know leveling of thought
that we had only fifty years ago or for
sure 100 years ago is is now has run its
course and now we have to try to find to
understand that in fact the world has
levels like it manifests itself in
hierarchies of beings and you can't you
can't avoid that do you think that it
was necessary to kind of clean up all
the symbolic
with symbolic thinking is that it can
get really messy and get really
associative I mean you can have a very
rich dialogue with the tarot deck but
you can also kind of get lost in it
right and just allow it to see
everywhere you know you can kind of go
astray in the scientific mindset is to
snap it down into a literal this than
that kind of way so was it not necessary
to kind of go through that at least to
contact the physical world in a way
where we can completely master it or
manipulate it I think I think I think
yes if what you want is to make better
pavement or to you know to have
energy-efficient windows or whatever
like whatever it is that technology does
and science does but when you try to
turn that thought back on the human
person you run into serious problems
like you run into serious problems
because because we do have hierarchical
thought we do have we do have we do use
metaphor we do use analogies we are we
are beings that thrive on meaning and on
analogy and on pattern and so if you and
so if you just try to eliminate that
when analyzing a human person then you
then you run into serious problems and
so although let's say an illogical
thinking is it can be problematic can be
messy it's also the way in which you can
move up the different levels like the
different levels of being it you can't
if you want to understand a let's say
how a group works or a city or a nation
if you can't understand the analogy
between a person and a city and a nation
if you don't see that there are
analogies that those different levels of
being then you're gonna really you're
gonna have some serious problems you
know I do see that like my original
diagnosis when I first started talking
about just the Evergreen phenomenon on
YouTube was that they are trying to take
a societal the sociological level of
thinking about groups and apply it to
the individual and it completely
destroys the individual on a variety of
levels beginning with their agency
responsibilities their self-worth their
self-respect and then the respect and
agency towards other people like it
completely ruins like the bonds between
the the particles because it's yeah
looking at well they're trying to
swallow and that's it so it so imagine
you have a hierarchy and this is what I
talk about when the problem of
hierarchies is that you can have a
hierarchy that tries to swallow its
parts right tries to completely consume
its parts so that its parts don't have
independent existence right and so that
is what happens in ideological groups
that's what happens in in the religious
sects like cults and stuff where it's
like everything or you know when you
have like a really charismatic leader
and then everybody just gets totally
sucked into that person it's as if the
the people the people that are under him
become almost like members of his body
like they're just extensions of of him
right and so that is that is that is
extremely dangerous when that happens
because the way one of the things I
talked about is long I tried to explain
that love is the balance between unity
and multiplicity hmm so if you let's say
you have a family and there's love in
that family there will be enough
communion they'll be enough to make you
our unit to make you a whole but the
very same process the love would also
make you respect the individuality of
each person and so the way to find a way
to balance is to always be moving
between unity and multiplicity to always
be finding a it's a hard to find the
exact it's never the same it it moves
but it's like a dance where you're
dancing and you're always trying to find
the balance between making sure
everybody has their own existence and
everybody is also aimed towards the same
goal or or moving towards towards each
other you know um and that's that's
communion that's love that's that's
basically what Christianity is supposed
to be you noticed it is to have that
that play and it happens so it happens
between people then it happens between
so you have in Christianity a this idea
that we're the body of Christ
and so it's like crisis above and we're
the body and then we are well fitted
together to true love so we love each
other and that makes us join with Christ
without losing our individuality and
then all of that it's like all of that
can be the way that the whole world
exists like all of creation all of
reality is always playing between
multiplicity and unity in order to find
that balance where everything can
continue to exist in in in in a cohesive
manner but when you have ideological
groups like you said it's what happens
is they try to impose the the higher
identity let's say the group identity
the race the bouquet and or whatever
they try to impose it in a manner which
is tyrannical all the way down it's like
everything has to just be a
manifestation of this thing that unites
us right so if you're a man it's like I
have identified the things of man and
you're that's all you are
you're not Benjamin you're not all these
other things that you are you're not a
complex system of different aspects
you're just a man Finn I'm gonna judge
you completely based on that one thing
and that's that destroys the world like
you can't the world can't exist that way
well it's interesting because and I
don't mean to offend anybody by saying
this but if that rigidity of thought
like that that man category is your full
existence then that defines every aspect
of your character but then that doesn't
really work in this system of thought so
they they build in the self ID clause
where now you can identify with the
other category and nobody can question
you you can just jump entirely into this
other category and get all of the you
know the strengths and weaknesses of
this completely other category so it's
one way to like do a loophole that
actually shows how maddening these
categories are yeah but it's an
interesting thing because it also but in
it also ends up half the same thing
happens in that case to even almost to a
higher degree where you know especially
in these kind of variant in these
variant like sexual identities
like when someone latches on to an
identity even if there is a thousand
even there's like a hundred of them then
it's almost as if I mean they're
swallowed up by that thing and so it's
as if it ends up being all they talk
about
oh they belly horses or Oh their whole
identity has been swallowed up by this
one thing whereas usually it's like
that's a you or I it's like I yes I am a
man and but I'm also I'm also the father
and I'm also I also had this job and I
also have interest and I also have and
these things and I'm also a member of a
church a member of this it's like so
it's like I have all these aspects of my
personality which are which are dancing
together in order to create Jonathan
petrol but like there's not one aspect
of myself which is completely swallowing
me you know yeah and I think that that's
that's that's a really it's a dangerous
because it's really difficult it's it's
really difficult to talk with people to
whom that has happened like if you meet
someone that has been completely
swallowed up by that one identity I mean
and it can be anyway anything it can be
raised to be nation to you meet someone
who is like super nationalistic it's as
if you can't it's really difficult to
talk to them because they they're so
like their visors are on so straight you
know and then they interpret everything
through their thing it's like meeting a
conspiracy theorist you know it's like
they they have this one thing and it's
like the whole world has to fit and this
one thing and they can't view other
other other other types of relationships
mm-hm and how do you have you seen
people like go through that and then
come out the other side and have you
seen that kind of breakdown oh yeah I
think I think it is possible I think it
is possible to not I think it is I think
it is pop it is possible to be possessed
by something and it really is a a form
of possession you know it is possible to
be possessed and then to kind of free
yourself from the
from possession and I think I mean I
think I've seen it in the past few years
I've seen a lot of that I think Jordan
during Peterson has kind of broken down
a bunch of doors in that sense where
people some people who were really kind
of caught up in an ideology on both
sides of the of the fence have been able
to kind of clear the open their visors
up a little bit and be able to see that
the world is bigger than your thing like
though that that identities you can't
reduce everything to one identity it
just doesn't doesn't work that way or
even just a multiplicity of identities
yes how do you what are some of the
steps that you think that that could
happen or help that process facilitate
that process of man identity idolatry
there's some sort of complex there yeah
man I think for sure for sure I think
that one of the things that can help is
contact with other people in the sense
that a lot of time these is like narrow
narrow furrows are dug because you end
up in these you know where they could
eat colonies these bubbles or whatever
these these uh these ideological bubbles
and so so so people aren't actually
meeting others who are different from
them and that they just don't have other
identities that are not even they're not
even in your on your spectrum like you
know yeah especially it's so funny
because it's like you meet the the
really woke types and I always want like
I wish a lot of the world types would go
and just hang out with just poor people
and realize that even it's so funny
because then even in terms of racism you
know I used to be I actually used to be
pretty easily pretty woke myself like
when I was a teenager I was the guy who
would always like stand up and if
someone was making some kind of racial
joke I would always call them out in
public and like anyways but there's
always the guy calling out the guy
that's calling everybody hey there you
go that's good but
when I started meeting like poor people
I realized that they they just had
another DISA completely other way of
looking at things completely other way
of and so you you go to a poor
neighborhood where there's you you meet
a poor white guy who has way more chance
to have in in his job around him to have
people from other races and he'll have a
kind of weird like a kind of weird low
level racism to him you know and it's
all it's it's it's inwards and it's kind
of like ah these guys are like this
these guys like that and it's it's kind
of off-putting at first then when you
when you look at them and you kind of
explore their world and realize okay
yeah they say that but then they'll have
lunch with this guy was Mexican or this
guy was from here or whatever and you
know it's like if you ask them it's like
oh no it's not it's not a big deal like
he's not like that you know and and it's
not thought out but there's like an
organic reality which is that even
though they can use certain words and
they have certain discourse it tends to
it tense in real life they actually have
more contact with other groups than
these like these like liberal woke
elites that have barely any contact with
people from other other types of people
and and and so they're policing their
language and their policing their
thoughts but they they're not actually
engaging with people that are different
from them and so it's like I would wrap
them I really prefer some some
working-class guy who once in a while
will say something that is off-putting
and kind of racist but in reality is way
more is actually probably way more in
way more possible he's gonna end up
dating a Mexican girl or some Vietnamese
girl or whatever just because in real
life it's like you know it's like he's
actually in contact with people from
other groups yeah that makes sense but
that what do you think end of the
thought that I at some point I've kind
of come to you where it's like there's
that there's there's there's this weird
political thing and then there's just
reality but it's like people are messy
people say stupid things people people
don't think things out but if they're
just basically good people in the end
it's not going to it's gonna play out
fine you know
it seems that there is a there's some
sort of we brought a purity earlier and
it seems like on that that kind of
earthy blue-collar racism it's they're
playing with or they're just evincing a
natural category and they're playing
with the category by pointing it out and
they they even know that this is a this
is a way that they can distinguish
themselves from the pure class the
aristocrats in a way so it's kind of
like virtue signaling among their kind
they can take the joke and give the joke
they're free to do that in a way whereas
the aristocrats are the puritanical
class aren't able to do that but the
danger is is when you have somebody that
starts playing around with that rhetoric
on the national scale which which trump
did and continues to do and I'm not
going to say that Trump is necessarily
fascist but he likes to he likes to play
with that and and it gets really a
little too close to comfort because you
can start to play around with those once
those those kind of earthy friendly
tensions yeah it replicated on another
scale they actually do turn into tyranny
no I agree no I agree I agree that that
you do see that and you do see that in
some populist movements where the let's
say the leader will spa normal tensions
or just normal differences that exist
you know that people notice and make
jokes about or whatever and then they
can use it to to get attention and also
to unify you know because they do it
does work like you can unify someone by
pointing to to a stranger like it
actually works you know it works it
works in the social justice world as
much as it works on the right-wing it's
like you can find the person who who has
to be cancelled then you make your group
stronger you know and so I see I
definitely I definitely agree that it
can it can happen and it does happen and
it definitely has happened in history
that's for sure it's interesting because
the Bernie Sanders tweeted a couple
weeks ago about how billionaire
billionaires shouldn't exist or
something like that which is interesting
it was like this politics of
this unity by anger unity by hatred and
and I've always just wary of that but
they it seems like there's a well yeah
and then it's like okay 150,000 Aires
should they I think says I think I think
is there a word for that hundred
thousand Aires a millionaire I'm not a
millionaire hey birdie
you shouldn't exist what are you talking
about well that's interesting because it
seems like a tactic to pick a group that
you can't that you would slander
yourself to defend if I started to
defend a billionaire like there's a
built-in incentive not to defend the
billionaire it's it's this little hack
and the same rhetoric with anti racism
if you start to criticize anti racism
that means because you're racist
straight like it's built in and I don't
know if it's purposely built in or not
but it just works that way to read the
self-reinforcing system that then leads
to these done this road of categorical
thinking yeah and you have both you you
you have both sides and that's the
history of the twentieth century or the
nineteen to twentieth century it's like
you you have let's say the left or on
the left you'll have the desire to
criticize the air aristocracy because
like you said on that on that side
anybody who's above you is fair game
right yeah and then you have the other
side which is that anybody who is
strange anybody who is who is an
exception and he's on which is on the
margin is fair game you know and and the
thing that's interesting is that on both
on both sides you end up dealing with
the minority like you're you're dealing
with that yeah Norah T of people and so
it's easy to focus on them because we're
the majority they're the minority either
the aristocracy or the the foreigners or
the the the people who are weird are
just different from us and so we can
just like we can we can point to them in
and say it's their fault that everything
is is is going wrong so it's the same
game you know yeah you just made me
think because there's that term punching
up
which the left allows you to punch up
whereas the rights more that you punch
out you punch to the out-group and it's
interesting I'm totally getting woowoo
the symbolic here but like it's the the
left has a problem with authority in the
on the vertical axis and the the right
will kind of vilify that which is the
horizontal axis or the the outsider in a
way yeah and it really is I always say
like this I've been saying this forever
that I think the modern world is adi
incarnation it's as we move away from
Christianity we're actually seeing a adi
incarnation and so we things ten things
are pulling apart in a manner so for
example like you you would that cross
that is how reality exists right for
those two to come together right for but
that we let's say the inevitability of
hierarchy but that the reason for
hierarchy is so that those that are
above care for those that are below like
that let's say that's the Christian
answer let's say that's the that that's
a Christian description of the world but
if you have if you pull it apart then
it's like you have just hierarchies that
are hierarchies of power and then you
end up having the grumbling of the of
the lower lower groups who are grumbling
against the authority and so it's like
it's pulling apart no so and then it's
it gets really crazy at some point
because at some point that that thinking
can become very extreme where where you
let's say you actually think that those
that are different from you that say the
foreigners or the the people outside of
your country are better than you like
that's the extreme of of let's say the
the left versions like then and then you
have the idea that the the people that
are different from you or outside of you
are parasites they're rats they're
insects they're you know like in the
Nazi era or the Tutsi the Tutsi genocide
it's like those are these are the
extremes that we have to be really
careful not to not to go to because
they're easy to magical immigrant I was
just reading a write-up at Evergreen
about they talk about the magical
outsider you know you're like okay
really okay this special it's just
falling into
this do this dialectic this like this
breaking a part of this that break a
part of the world and then coming to see
everything in that that that that digit
there's gonna come a point and I think
it's already there where people are
gonna think that like robots are better
than us that robots are more human than
we are we've already seen narratives
like that already seen narratives where
I think was it when it was it at the
iRobot where X ma it's like the the
robot that is that is moral and we are
immoral it's the it's the it's the Apes
Planet of the Apes that's a great
example the Apes are the good guys the
humans are the bad guys that is that is
that dangerous narrative of seeing that
which is outside as better than the
inside why is that so dangerous because
it devalues see if you're gonna cease to
exist but or what does it do I let's see
how come of that well the outcome of
that is that you're I mean the outcome
that is that you you'll you'll you'll
drown like you'll just drown and you'll
stop you'll just cease to exist because
because you can't let's say how can I
say this it's like it's like if you I
can give you an example I can give you
an example of I try always try to bring
it close to a home so that you know
right so you can see cuz if you make it
too big then people stop seeing it but
like you you you have your house and
then let's say you have that thinking
where you think that those that are
outside of your house are better than
you that they're magical that they're
that they're this this image of
everything
and so then you so let's say you you you
you see someone who's in trouble outside
and you say you know you see a homeless
person you say well you should come live
in my house right because you're
actually better than me and and you you
invite them in and then you invite
another one in and you invite another
one let's say you invite 50 because
there's an indefinite amount of them
there's always more on the outside than
there is on the inside hmm that's just
the nature reality of any identity
always has more on the outside so you're
like okay well let's just invite
everybody who needs something to come
live in my house well how long how long
before you cease to exist like how long
before your family is not if it's just
not there's an exist anymore
I would say even before you reach like
the equal amount of people in the family
like it's you even let's say you're
three people or four people in your
family and you have another three people
like live in your house your family's
gonna stop existing so it's just that's
just reality it's like and it's it's
like that for I don't know how can I say
this is it's like that for everything is
there a word that's the opposite of
hierarchy or not the opposite of
hierarchy isn't like just inverting the
hierarchy but like what is that that
principle that organizes the the
horizontal plane is there one do we just
take it as granted that geography exists
and that there's a line around us to me
that let's say the counterweight or that
balance of hierarchy you could call it
something like a frame or you could call
it a question um you could you can you
could call it a space all those images
they're really feminine images yeah what
talks about Korra like the space he has
a book on that and it is very good in
terms of trying to understand the
problem of articulating the space
without naming it because this is one of
the reasons why it's difficult to talk
about it's difficult to show the value
of of the feminine because you have to
be careful not to make it masculine as
soon as you try to show the value of it
you know it's like if you give a metal
to the feminine it's is it that is that
then then it's like you're playing the
game you're playing the masculine game
by doing that you're you know you're
giving a prize you're you're doing all
these things which are kind of like
these weird hierarchical things of
winners and losers and all that but but
it's like if you want to actually admire
venerate the feminine and it's another
game it's another it's another type of
interaction hmm does that happen through
art better than words I guess the visual
rather or the the sensual rather the
musical maybe yeah
maybe I think I think that I think that
like I said the understanding the value
of a question understanding the value of
a of the opening or the frame of a
discourse something usually don't see
but is there it's necessarily there I
think that that is how you but it's it's
usually something there's there's like a
weird secretive power to it it has like
a secret power you could say and and
it's like once you understand let's say
that without a question there's no
answer that the question comes first
quest right the quest comes first that
the vd and so it's like the need comes
first right so it's like that is
extremely powerful it's it's even its
powerful if you understand it even in
terms of let's say a religious language
which is that you pray you pray so that
the world will happen in a certain way
you open up a space for the divine to
manifest itself
that is extremely powerful but if
there's a there's a yeah it is
mysterious we I remember trying to
during my youth group era trying to get
people to define what prayer is and you
know because they would they would talk
about what it's not like you're wishing
for a new car but like really getting
into the nitty-gritty of how do you have
an intention that's open like how do you
become how you become a flashing cursor
you know where where you're not
overstepping the bounds of reality but
you're you're allowing that space to to
happen and and initiative it's a it's a
whole level of psychological preparation
or like kind of this facing towards
reality that that's like got me into
studying mysticism more because that the
the direction that that goes is is
preparing your awareness and and
becoming aware of your consciousness and
working like I agree with you and I
think that it's a I think that that it
to understand the the power of a
question and to understand the the power
of opening up a space or presenting a
need which is authentic I think is is
extremely powerful like I tell the story
a lot but there's a story in the gospel
in at the wedding of Cana which is
really revealing in terms of
understanding this where there's this
idea that Christ is hidden that Christ
has not yet shown himself to the world
no one knows who he is really the only
person who knows who he is is his mother
and his mother comes to him and that
this wedding they run out of wine and
she comes to him and she says they ran
out of wine and it's like and then
Christ answers he says he says my time
has not yet come which is like a crazy
answer to act it to say to something
like there's not enough there's no more
wine but wouldn't you understand the
subtext when you understand is that
she's saying she's opening the door
she's saying here's a problem you're the
you're the divine you're that you're the
you're the logos you're the you're the
answer now you manifest yourself in this
space I'm giving you the space I'm
saying here's a problem and so and what
he understands is that if he does that
he's actually entering on he's opening
he's starting on down a road which is
gonna lead him to die basically and so
she it's like she's saying she's like
she's opening the space she's saying
now's the time I'm up here is the
question you start you start to answer
it and so she's actually acting as like
this the opening up of his ministry in
the opening up of his entry of showing
himself to the world it's like it's her
request which starts it and you see that
in the history of Christianity all
through the history of Christianity it's
crazy
it's a systematic you can do a search on
your own there's always a woman who
converts first so for example though the
of constantine the the mother of of
vladimir of kiev the the the it's always
like a wife or a mother for every king
every emperor every important person
that converts there's always a woman who
converts first and then there's a secret
exchange we don't hear about the
exchange there's like a secret thing and
then the the visible figure converts and
then like the whole country converts or
whatever but that's the structure of
being it's like that well what about
that coming into being in our world
right now like how would that that
prompt surface in this time right now
where there's these really extreme rigid
madness is happening you know or people
are completely lost their their balance
what what what's the frame what's the
what's the secret question what's what's
the what's the need right now how do we
how do we get to a point where we start
to ask that and create that space for
that central figure that centrist crazy
that's tough I never I don't know why
like it's like I haven't even thought
about that but I should be thinking
about that like of all people watch of
you thinking about that and what's that
like what's the question or what's the
opening up hmm I mean because it seems
like if we look at Peterson's work so we
can work at Peterson's work but I'd like
to look at your work like the way that
your work is interacting with people is
that you are you're saying wait there's
something more here there's look at look
at this movie there's something more
here like what is what is playing out
here there's a maybe this is so maybe I
know it's like you got me thinking in a
way that I never thought before which is
good which is good it may be that is
that in a way that's been what I've been
trying to do from the from the beginning
in the sense that it's like what one of
the things that I'm trying to do is
actually help people see the world
differently so it's like I'm not trying
to change the terms of what's being said
I'm just trying to say
your your frame your frame in wit by
which you interpret the world is lacking
you need something which is more
connective and connects the different
layers of reality together so I have to
think about it maybe that in a way is a
feminine move like in the sense of
saying it's like it's not the terms it's
not that it's not the things that are in
the story it's the fact that you've lost
the frame and because of that you don't
understand how powerful the story is you
don't understand how deep it goes and
how it connects everything together
because you you're you've limited you
know you're limited in your frame maybe
that's in be interesting to think about
that you know what maybe I'm gonna get
in trouble for saying this but like
we're secret feminists in a way and in
the way well in a way like I'm thinking
about like my I had this I have this
analogy about like the work that I do
and that it's the it's a metaphor based
on like these role-playing games like
these online role-playing games where
five characters come together to defeat
a problem and there's there's a tank
person who takes all the damage and has
everybody focus their anger on him and
then there's the DPS which are the ones
who do all the damage to kill the the
enemy and then there's the healer that
that keeps everybody alive and the way
that my channel works out is that I have
my tank which is my documentary or like
the big question that that I'm exploring
and a long form then I had the DPS which
is the little mouthy snarky tiny videos
but like what keeps it all together I
think is the healer which would be the
the interviewer where I am no longer the
actor I am the you know I'm the audience
I'd be I become the audience and and
that that's principally a feminine
spacial be had totally right the
interviewer is a great is actually an
amazing image of what you're talking
about
because what you're doing is you by
asking the questions you're you're
framing the the discourse and you can
give the authenticity bye-bye
framing the discourse properly you you
have the power to open or close down
spaces and we see it we see it all the
time because when we watch mainstream
interviews or you watch certain types of
interviews you can see that the
interviewer is actually trying to shut
it down like in their question they're
actually trying to completely shut down
the conversation but but if you can be a
good interviewer and you're able to open
up spaces then I think you're right that
that will be a healing thing just that
without even like is that not even
saying anything even if in your videos
you can say things that people will find
offensive if when you engage people in
conversation you you have this desire to
open up a real space for them to exist I
think like you said I think that's
unbeatable so yeah that's a great
analogy the video game wins the video
game thing is great I love that you know
there's that you you brought that image
which is really actually nightmarish to
me like somebody having the power to
open and close space like that's very
like primordial power to say we I'm
gonna close that down I'm it's like this
ability to control possibility not
actuality but like the precondition of
actuality which is possibility which is
and the thing is that most people don't
see that most people don't see those
preconditions and so there's something
magical about that capacity you know
there's something magical because people
don't realize that what you're doing if
you're if you're asking the right
questions then people will at the end
they might think that it's only the
person answering the questions who had a
place who is who is who is discussing
but they can't see the pre the opening
like you said the pre illogical the
opening of the space they don't see how
without that things would be completely
different and so it is an extremely
powerful thing so if you look at my
videos like you said we're secret
feminists it's like if you look at the
logo for my my youtube channel you you
took a while for people to realize that
it's actually the creation of Eve that's
the story that's the image you have to
you have to see it's like because I
think that well I think that the modern
world is overly masculine if it's it's
too masculine it's actually the feminine
which is disappearing from the world and
so I think that I think that's a really
dangerous place to be in and and we see
it in the reduction of community the
destruction of private space all of this
is is being eclipsed everything is
becoming public everything is becoming a
form of of showing yourself you know you
know voyeurism and showing yourself it's
everything is that and so I think
helping to open up the feminine space
and in a reverential way I think it's
something that is a really or both wow
yeah that this seems like we're ending
on a high note we should probably yeah
we've been going for like 45 minutes we
could totally we could totally finish
here and I think that'd be good cool
it's always uh it's always a pleasure I
would say it's more often got me the
same something that I've never liked you
definitely got me on a line that I'm
gonna finish this conversation I'm gonna
go sit down and be okay all right
benjin's and Benjamin's messing with me
I gotta gotta get through this just open
open to the question that's right weird
right yeah yeah I feel like full now I
feel like I need to go think like we
started poking something yeah well
thanks for doing what you do by the way
it's it's great yeah well you too man I
mean it's amazing and I'm so glad that
you guys are you're having so much
success and and you know you have like a
Clips channel and it's fun it's
definitely fun and it what's fun is like
the clips channel for example is gonna
be run entirely by volunteers it's like
people are gonna be running it for me
and so it's it's for me it's great
because it it's like people who are
willing to make clips so that I know I'm
gonna end up knowing what it is that I'm
saying that people are really latching
on to and so it's like that's gonna be
helping for me because then
I can be mindful of that when I'm
speaking so I'm excited about that I
think what that's the thing that's been
the most exciting for me is to watch
people aren't kind of awesome have a new
vision of the world and then kind of run
with it like there's that they're like
right there's a new podcast coming out
new Orthodox symbolism podcast that just
started and there are different
different people trying to get into that
same space so that's exciting it's a lot
of fun well earlier you were I can't
really reconstitute what we were talking
about but I wanted to ask about that you
were talking about like the individual
the the that if you frame everything in
love then the individual can go to the
family the family can fit into the unit
and then going up and down and I'm like
well you're putting your individuality
right out there and and engaging with
the community all the time and I was
just I wanted to ask about that but I
don't know how to frame that like
watching that process of like you being
a particle and then watching something
grow around you and this in this social
space yeah it's it's it's it's exciting
it's dangerous I have to be careful it's
like it's hard it's hard you have to be
I mean it's like it you always have to
fight the tendency to think that is you
like oh I'm doing this like I'm you know
this is great you know so it so it is
dangerous
luckily I have a you know I go to
confession that helps for that but it's
like the the pride element is sometimes
difficult in that in that sense like
some people talk about your your ideas
to talk about your videos so it's like
okay okay Jonathan but it's good my wife
smacks me around like that's great she's
she's like she has no no no she has she
has no no time for my arrogance and
that's really useful that's another
positive aspect of the negative feminine
oh yeah keeps you in line it's great
it's great
you
and talking about trading and
participating in society at least for
now it is still possible to engage and I
designed some some new things for for
the Christmas season of two t-shirts and
some new merchandise people seem to be
appreciated and it was even shared by
Rod Dreher on Twitter the t-shirt on the
six days of creation so check it out you
still have a few days to order it so
then it will arrive before Christmas so
if you are interested go ahead and
thanks a lot everybody for your support
don't forget to subscribe also to the
clips channel which is putting stuff all
almost every day I think thank you for
the volunteers where I get involved in
that I will talk to everybody very soon